we turned to the phone lines and one of
the top y receiving prospects in all of
the NFL Draft is on the phone line
he was almost two full seconds faster
than me at this year's NFL Scouting
Combine with his four to 740 and so much
more about him that has so many Scouts
ready to maybe make him the first wide
receiver name called and a couple of
Thursday's from now he is Henry rugs the
third of Alabama football how are you
Henry
um I am doing fine what's your training
like right now sir um pretty much just
finding what I can do you know I got a
little weight said in the house so
listen ways trying to do something every
day and wherever I find green grasses
the way I can do a little you know field
work you're lifting weights huh as a
like what what does that do to help
lifting weights for you I mean yeah I'm
did it this time the you know bill over
by the strip time-to-time get a little
bigger okay get a little more swole
it's funny you know cuz Deion Sanders
who I work with always hates it whenever
we show defensive backs lifting weights
at the combine because he said he never
had to put Jerry Rice across his chest
and lift him that's was his way of
saying that so so the fact that you're
out there in the weight room that
probably makes you a little bit of a
difference maker and the wide receiver
front Henry huh I'm just trying to get
that that physical side of me you know
going into a man game now so gotta be a
little more physical and have that you
know that edge with me okay so for those
who maybe need to know what makes you
tick what makes you tick Henry why are
you as good as you have shown on the
football field in your estimation
probably this one the motivation I have
no because my best friend just gave me
you know that that confidence and that
driver to be the best at everything and
always compete and then taking on that
my competitiveness I just I never you
know never like to lose when you say
your friend who is were you referring to
Henry
Roderick Scott
now tell me about Roderick and I know
that you give a three-fingered salute
after every school touchdown you score
but tell me about him it was I mean they
got it that I met when I was younger and
I mean I met him through competition
playing basketball we became closer when
we got to high school and pretty much we
just became like family and you know he
was the guy that that saw something in
me before I saw something in myself and
he just he pushed me to be be the best
that I could be and help me develop that
that confidence and the mentality that
that no one should tell you what you can
and can't do that you can always be the
best so for those who may not know his
story walk us through his story and
again why you while you revere him so
that you memorialize him when he scores
when you score well once again like I
say he was just you know I got it that
motivated me to do everything we became
best friends you know I was the one he
was the only guy that you know knew
almost everything about me and what was
going on in my life my best friend
no treating him like a brother and
tragedy he was killed in a car accident
in the car that I was supposed to be in
and possibly driving because I got sick
and you know it's just just honoring his
memory every day Henry rugs a third here
on the Rich Eisen show all right and so
who you mentor your game after who do
you think you would remind people of
Henry I can't say one person I'm I got
it you know that that tries to be
different tried to have my own you know
unique twisted things and you know I
take I kind of take out there more than
one person I try to get you know get
some from from different receivers and
different guys incorporating into my
gaming make a different mixture so then
who do you admire growing up who did you
say I want to make I want to be like
that guy when I get to the NFL and now
you're about to get into the NFL Henry
okay big is honestly as a kid growing up
I never watch the ball okay now you grew
up in Alabama didn't you Henry yeah okay
that that's
I think you know I know it's a free
country and we have a first amendment I
think that's illegal to say growing up
in Alabama correct you can't just say
that
oh so alright let me let me walk through
this the sport you would you were hoops
guy is that who you were younger or
still are or yeah I say basketball would
my was my favorite thing to do okay and
then how'd you get into football then
gladly younger you know I played Little
League play one year uh-huh okay great
and I mean I was I did pretty good you
know at those at those stages and I was
pretty much just called down in high
school saying that I couldn't you know I
couldn't perform on that level born on
high school level I couldn't do this
they couldn't do that and even though
the coaches always told me that I
wouldn't be a basketball player because
I wasn't tall enough or I didn't do this
well enough and it was pretty much just
uh once again a competitive thing that I
went out just to show him what I could
he couldn't do okay so now you know some
NBA NFL players think that they can be
in the NBA I would prefer to say a lot
of tight ends have had the opportunity
to maybe go in the NBA chose the NFL
instead do you think you could be a to
support two sports stars you had that
opportunity
Henry how good are you know how good as
well now I haven't been working on the
game like that you know back in high
school when I was you know when I was
with rod and will going to the gym three
or four times a day I believe I could
have stood it a good fit of tennis okay
so now who was your game what what's
your game looked like there I mean who
would you have modeled yourself after
there at 511 and weird but I mean that's
which means what you don't you you you
get triple doubles coming out of yours
oh and basically you're saying Henry I'm
uh I'm high and I always do everything
at full speed and I'm a half liar
Russell Westbrook is aiming quite high
Henry I mean you could definitely be him
and you could definitely beat him and
a race that's for sure that is that is
for sure
Henry rugs the third here on the Rich
Eisen show okay so what's the
competition like with you in Jerry Judy
look walk me through that because it
looks like it's gonna be up to the two
of you or CD lamb to be the first name
called is there is there a competition
between you two guys as far as the draft
I mean we're I mean we like family we're
happy for you know each other and you
know whatever happens is happening but
at the end of the day of course we're
competing you know for a job and just
like Alabama we competed to you know
just to make each other better and I
mean I felt like that's that's gonna
push push all of us over there you know
over there is and make us you know
better players and better people well
where does that competition come from is
that the head coach would he be
fostering all of that stuff some that
that just started know within within the
rules we all wanted to be the best in it
was a it was a pretty talented room so
we all you know we all pretty much knew
that we had to take advantage of every
opportunity that we had and make the
most out of everything and that did I
mean I just started the competition
between us to make sure that we were the
most most efficient guys that that were
playing okay so who was the most vocal
guy in telling to or to get you the ball
the more the more vocal guy when it came
to he would go to two or more me I was
more laid-back I didn't really say much
you know unless I unless I thought I
needed to but Smith it was the guy that
went to the coaches so we are you know
we all had a different one about the two
coaches who are the coaches we you know
if it's in the heat of the game and
committed things you see some here go
here go over to you know like he'll go
over the stock until hey I see it so
telcos we can say asking is come to me
right Judy
he's like I said he he'll run the tool
and Tim like a fight no look at me on
this one look for me on this one right
you know I speak when when I feel like
you know I need to make my play and but
that that did hi everybody
you know what about it well you speak
with your feet Henry rugs the third do
you not that's what you spent with yeah
yes I'd love you know with with my place
right and then you speak on the film to
you speak in the film room you point out
look at me right there with green grass
correct yeah I bet I love that you so
you were just you're the least vocal
essentially out of all the guys on your
team all right
Henry I've been asking this question of
all the Alabama Crimson Tide players
that have come on the show to uh we just
had Jedrek wills yesterday Jerry was on
last week
Jerry Judy was on last week I asked him
all the same question what's the most
upset you've seen Nick Saban ever
[Music]
probably arable iron ball walk me
through that one Henry it was just it
was I feel like it was a he said it was
the start of the game you know even
before the game in the locker room he's
I guess he didn't he wasn't feeling the
same energy you know and he was kind of
kind of coming at us like that and I
mean it was something just carried over
you know throughout the game and you
know he he let us do that better tonight
so did he ever come up to you did you
ever do something that required his
attention with you specifically Henry oh
yeah first me year versus Arkansas I'm
well I'm most two points I got the first
one back right in the second one in a
second when I had to move and yet I was
that was a time where he he kind of came
at me and you know let me know some
things and you know that didn't end too
well let you know some things that's
one way to put it how do how did it make
you a better player though Henry how did
he improve your talk with that I mean it
just made me focus know focus more and
you know you gotta pay attention to the
little thing that was one thing he
always told my hands too low on punt
returners okay and you know that was
something that that was something I
really didn't see or didn't really feel
until I watched the film and you know he
pointed it out there would you like to
know the answers of your other teammates
to the questions Henry yeah okay to uh
said the most upset he saw Nick was
after he took that sack before he threw
the touchdown to win the national
championship game oh yeah you remember
that one right yeah he said however was
only topped by the fact that when Nick
despite winning it went up to two to
coach him on don't do that again and to
a kind of gave him oh but what about
that throw response that is that's what
he that was his answer
Jedrek wills his answer was that any
against oklahoma after a penalty backed
them up he had a false start and then an
illegal procedure in the consecutive
snaps after that you remember that one
yeah okay very good
were you like looking out of the saudi
or are to see how coaches handling all
that at the time you can see on the on
the plate
or where you play it back on the
television and and wills backed up what
Jerry Judy had to say the most upset
Jerry ever saw him was at practice where
some poor member of the staff handed
Nick the wrong straw hat said that that
was only matched by the time that
somebody threw the coach's shoes out
without asking and then gave him a new
pair of shoes that weren't as good that
was another one
um am i bringing back memories for you
Henry
right now yeah you actually yeah this
made me think of another moment uh-oh
what game was it I wouldn't say it was
attempting something in the playoffs the
semifinal game
mm-hmm and we were up and I guess so we
threw a pass he end up getting here to
get like ran over on the sideline okay
and he he went the decodable and you
know and you know let him have it
because he he wanted to run the ball and
run the clock out it we threw a fast and
I really felt like it was because he I
ran over it worse though right it's like
he called me what he wanted run instead
there's a pass and then the result of
the past is him getting run over to that
probably made it worse that probably
went great
but it helps you get ready for the next
level doesn't it I mean you probably
have seen it all Henry that's probably
gonna give you a little bit of help I
think a leg up coming in to the Li here
what do you think okay hey Henry thanks
to the time really appreciate it I look
forward to seeing what you do at the
next level and I you have a good shot at
being the first name called and if you
do I'll be thinking of you and will will
come regardless of where you're drafted
once you're drafted get you back here
and just talk about it okay
now I look forward to it thanks to call
Henry you take care of yourself alright
you got Henry rugs at third right here
in the Rich Eisen show